so i i had a uh quandary a question for
you
imagine that you guys are launched into
space
um how do you guys function as a crew
what roles do you guys take up who goes
insane first basically give me an idea
of how this space travel goes say you're
just stuck in the space capsule for
a couple months traveling to mars or
something okay i have very strong
feelings about this first of all it
would be a similar dynamic to what you
see here we don't change as people it's
just in zero gravity and under
constrained conditions
i don't think i go crazy first because i
would
posit
that i'm gone already
i i think i'm i'm unbalanced now on
earth i don't think i change that
drastically when you put me in in space
i think girly goes crazy first cause
sona i've seen you be very chill in very
intense situations gourley you're a
fussy fellow who likes your life the way
you like it and all your little
tchotchkes would be floating around and
your ukulele strings this is a guy who
carries a briefcase telling me this
i don't have a briefcase i've seen you
come in with a little brown leather
briefcase it's a no it's a that's a
mailman's bag it's a male 1 that's even
worse yeah but no but no no no let me
finish here because you're you're just
wrong you
you like your life the way you like it
everything is just so
and sona and i have been in the trenches
and some crazy stuff over the years i
think you have always
you know had your little muddled drink
just when you wanted it you've always
enjoyed uh you know the music you wanted
to hear when you wanted to hear it and
the little snacks you wanted just when
you wanted them i got smith to ship all
this up there for me right now no but
it's going to be floating around that's
just it that's even better it's going to
be floating around and you're going to
get very uptight and you're going to say
where's my uh
yeah
what do you mean yeah where's my little
i don't even know what he's talking
about i well no where's my little
where's my money i'm definitely not
going crazy first i know that's for sure
and i'm not because i'm there
and that's what i was gonna say you're
already uh crazy but how are you gonna
do without an audience for two months oh
all my bits in zero gravity i get to do
every bit that i've been trying out
since i was a kid in zero gravity i'm i
don't need anybody i'm going to be so
happy up there i swear to god
me doing my shtick
in zero gravity i mean first the first
two years are going to be me doing the
string dance in zero gravity and and no
one can even get it doesn't come back
down though conan the string doesn't
come back just keep going up you're
gonna be stuck in the position and
you're going to have to manually force
your leg back down yeah you could eject
me from the spaceship and i could do one
pull on the string dance of and which
rocket me towards the sun little
thrusters yeah have you guys ever seen
the movie sunshine this is what would
happen yes you would end up like mark
strong in that movie they wouldn't hear
from us for
decades and then they'd find you burned
by the sun having murdered everybody in
the space station yeah okay but that's
still eating a potato yeah that's not
going that's not me going crazy that's
me realizing a dream oh
okay okay
oh he went crazy what did he do he
killed gourley oh
i don't think he went crazy
that's just normal
he's okay he achieved his lifelong
ambition
is my life in danger
no you're fine for now for now witnesses
that's so i think um i think uh it would
be a fantastic experience you know and i
think we could add greatly to science's
uh knowledge
uh of space
conan are you taking the lead role are
you the captain on this mission or are
you collecting excuse me he is i'm
muting what are you talking about
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute one of you two what are you doing
why is this up for debate
that's insane operate like a car fob
even like much less a phone or a
computer he's not wrong
it's called conan o'brien needs a friend
and you guys are terrific
um
smaller players but you can't put me
you can't make me answer to gourley or
answer to sona that's mad it's gonna be
called conan o'brien crashes a spaceship
he's not wrong here's the thing if
there's something mechanically wrong
that needs to be fixed like physically
somebody needs to actually fix it i
don't think you'll do that i know
gourley will do that i don't think you
are you handy you need me are you handy
the handiest one you are pretty handy no
but you're still not in charge uh scotty
on star trek
was not in charge the captain was in
charge and then he'd tell scotty get the
engines working and scotty would do it
that's the dynamic what if scotty
doesn't do it yeah but what are you
contributing uh i have an amazing
personality
um that doesn't matter in space guess
what i have zero gravity hair on earth's
gravity
what is that so imagine what it's gonna
be like up there you know i just don't
know what your value what you're
bringing to the table i have lots of
bits 28 years of america's love
hold on a second i'm doing the math
right now well i was on for 28 years i
want to say a solid three of america's
love
um but i i think
it's not even up for discussion i am the
alpha
and i will be in charge and i'm not
saying it's the elf i'm not saying it's
a good thing
i didn't say it was a good thing it's
just going to happen okay okay all right
well i uh i thank you guys for your time
and also for getting me probably fired
smith
guess what
smith mulliken you're the first man
ever on a kona fan to end the interview
yeah for your own good judgment and
sense of propriety and i i congratulate
you thank you
you